- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par monsieur Sébastien Chenu
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Sébastien Chenu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie,
des Finances et de l'industrie.
Parce que nous sommes partis de la
France travaille et de la France
qui aimerait travailler à ça.
Cette entreprise pourrait fermer.
C'est le dernier fabricant
français de roues de train dont
l'unique actionnaire chinois
a déclaré qu'il ne mettrait plus
un centime dans la société.
C'est 336 emplois dans le Nord.
Le savoir-faire et la productivité
ainsi que la qualité du travail
sont reconnus de tous.
Cette entreprise est menacée.
L'investisseur chinois a obtenu ce
qu'il voulait: les brevets, le
savoir-faire et la technologie.
Il est prêt à plier bagage.
Ce pillage des compétences
françaises de cette incapacité à
contraindre une entreprise
française comme la SNCF à passer
des commandes publiques pour
les roues de train en dit long sur
l'abandon de nos fleurons
industriels.
Cela en dit long
sur notre soumission.
En 2021, j'avais alerté
le ministre de l'Economie.
Je n'ai jamais eu de réponse.
Le mépris et la désinvolture...
Quel sort sera réservé à cette
entreprise et à ses salariés?
Qu'attendez-vous pour appliquer
la préférence nationale de la
commande publique, pour protéger
notre industrie, pour agir
concrètement?
Quand allez-vous vous occuper
enfin de l'économie française?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roland Lescure,
ministre délégué chargé de
l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure: Monsieur Chenu,
comme toujours, vous
instrumentalisez et vous
caricaturez la réindustrialisation
de la France, qui a commencé il y
a six ans.
C'est grâce à cette majorité.
Elle va se poursuivre.
En ce qui concerne l'entreprise
dont vous parlez, elle a été
reprise par un actionnaire chinois
il y a maintenant une dizaine
d'années, en 2014.
Cet actionnaire chinois a
réinvesti dans cette entreprise
plus de 100 millions d'euros.
Malgré cela, l'entreprise n'a pas
réussi à gagner des parts de
marché à l'international.
Vous le savez sans doute puisque
vous suivez cette entreprise
de près.
Cette entreprise a une capacité de
production de 100.000 roues par
an.
Si la SNCF achète toutes ces roues
à cette entreprise, elle en
achèterait 40.000 maximum par an.
Nous n'avons pas attendu votre
intérêt pour nous intéresser
de près à cette entreprise.
Nous avons mis en place une étude
indépendante qui montre qu'on a
deux défis: un outil de production
ancien et un défi de capacités de
production.
Depuis vendredi, nous avons plus
d'informations sur le
désengagement annoncé par
l'actionnaire.
Nous allons les convoquer à
nouveau.
Ils seront à Bercy demain.
Nous allons recevoir les
organisations syndicales pour
accompagner cette entreprise vers
la reprise.
Nous ferons tout pour.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Sébastien Chenu?
- Sébastien Chenu: On n'a pas
besoin d'une réponse de ChatGPT.
Bougez-vous!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le ministre?
- Roland Lescure: Vos bons mots,
vous pouvez vous les garder.
Depuis six ans, ce gouvernement a
créé plus d'emplois industriels
que vous n'en créerez jamais.
Il a recréé des entreprises, y
compris dans le Nord, où vous vous
nourrissez de la
désindustrialisation.
Nous allons continuer à agir et
vous allez continuer à parler!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Gosselin pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Philippe Gosselin: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Une crise sans précédent du
logement s'annonçait.
Elle est là.
Tous les acteurs le disent.
Le marché des transactions
immobilières est gelé.
Le mal-logement s'aggrave en
France.
Depuis six ans, il manque au moins
100.000 logements en France.
Cela touche tous les types
de logement.
On est en manque cruel.
Les causes sont multiples, mais
elles se cumulent.
Les taux d'intérêt ont augmenté.
Les crédits se sont resserrés.
Les banques sont devenues
frileuses.
Le foncier se fait rare.
Ce sont les blocages des projets
en zone RNU qui sont
les plus touchés.
Ce sont les PUI.
Et que dire du zéro
artificialisation?
On en est là.
C'est aussi la question des DPE.
Il y a des mesures nouvelles qui
leur sont adossées, avec les
passoires énergétiques qu'on
retire du marché...
C'est aussi des difficultés, avec
MaPrimeRénov', avec des
entreprises et des particuliers
qui attendent des paiements
aléatoires.
La coupe est pleine.
Il paraît que l'Europe va en
rajouter une couche.
La crise du logement est bien là.
Tout cela entretient
un fort ressentiment social.
Nos concitoyens n'en peuvent plus.
Le président de la République
avait annoncé un choc sur l'offre
des logements.
Il est là, mais pas
dans le sens souhaité.
Madame la Première ministre, que
comptez-vous faire pour soutenir
le logement et aider nos
concitoyens?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein, ministre délégué chargé de
la Ville et du Logement.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Philippe
Gosselin, le gouvernement agit.
Le gouvernement agit depuis six
ans pour le logement.
Vous avez commencé en parlant du
mal-logement.
Le plan logement a permis depuis
2018 à 440.000 personnes de
quitter la rue et d'entrer dans un
foyer.
Le logement, c'est aussi la
rénovation thermique.
C'est 1,5 million de chantiers qui
ont pu voir le jour.
C'est l'économie d'une ville égale
à la ville de Lyon.
Le gouvernement a agi pour
protéger les Français en mettant
en place tous les boucliers
tarifaires possibles sur le gaz et
l'électricité.
Ensuite, il y a des difficultés.
Vous savez très bien que le
logement est une responsabilité
partagée.
Il faut mobiliser les maires,
il faut leur donner envie
de construire.
Ils ont les capacités
Nous le faisons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
silence!
- Olivier Klein: Nos conclusions
seront annoncées bientôt.
Nous travaillons avec l'ensemble
du monde de logements privés ou
publics pour préparer une relance
à travers une action de la Caisse
des Dépôts et des conciliations.
Il s'agit d'une relance à travers
le contrat de confiance avec les
bailleurs sociaux, comme la
Première ministre l'a annoncé dans
sa feuille de route.
Ce document sera signé avant
l'automne.
Nous avons à travailler et nous
continuerons à travailler sur
cette crise du logement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Philippe Gosselin?
- Philippe Gosselin: Le
gouvernement est dans le déni
complet.
Vous nous dites que vous avez fait
beaucoup de choses, mais beaucoup
reste à faire.
On attend des mesures concrètes.
Si vous voulez éviter d'avoir des
casseroles au-delà des cuisines,
il va falloir prendre ce dossier à
bras-le-corps.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci...
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur...
Monsieur le ministre?
- Olivier Klein: Vous savez...
On peut faire le Tartuffe.
Le ZAN est un moyen de protéger
notre environnement.
Les PLU sont à la disposition des
élus locaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Un peu de silence.
La parole est uniquement au
président Jean-Louis Bourlanges
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Jean-Louis Bourlanges: Madame la
présidente, ce sera plus calme.
Madame la Première ministre,
monsieur le ministre, mes chers
collègues, nous célébrons
aujourd'hui l'appel à la
construction d'une Europe unie
lancée il y a 73 ans
par Robert Schuman.
L'Europe, c'est aujourd'hui deux
choses essentielles: la paix pour
vivre ensemble et la synergie
pour vivre libres.
Les Français aiment l'Europe.
Quand ils regardent le passé, ils
voient qu'elle a su mettre fin à
la guerre éternelle.
Les Français aiment l'Europe quand
ils regardent l'avenir, car ils
savent que seule l'union fait la
force.
Cet avenir est inédit.
J'oserais dire qu'il est
révolutionnaire.
Au cours des 20 dernières années,
l'Europe a été confrontée
à six défis majeurs.
Elle n'y a répondu
que de façon partielle.
Malgré les appels répétés du
président de la République, les
Européens sont globalement
incapables de répondre aux trois
questions qui déterminent les
réponses: qui, quoi et comment?
Qui sont les Européens?
C'est la question de l'identité
commune.
Quoi?
Que voulons-nous faire ensemble et
que voulons-nous continuer à faire
ensemble?
Comment?
C'est la question d'un désir de
construction commune.
Nos concitoyens vont retrouver foi
dans le projet commun à la
condition de se voir offrir
simultanément une vision claire
et des actions fortes.
Nous devons tenir ensemble les
deux bouts de la chaîne.
Nous avons besoin d'un calendrier.
Qu'est-ce que le gouvernement
entend faire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Nous traversons
des crises multiples marquées
par le retour de la guerre sur notre
continent, par la volonté
d'affirmation des superpuissances
et la nécessité de renforcer
notre indépendance énergétique,
industrielle, alimentaire
et stratégique.
Face à ces défis, pour peser et
bâtir notre souveraineté, plus que
jamais, la solution passe par
l'Union Européenne.
L'Europe est le bouc émissaire des
populismes et serait la cause de
tous leurs maux.
Ils oublient que c'est l'Europe
qui a permis une relance majeure
de l'économie après le Covid, que
c'est l'Europe qui nous permet
d'apporter une réponse ferme et
résolue face à l'agression russe
en Ukraine, que c'est l'Europe qui
nous permet d'avoir une ambition
climatique puissante et
coordonnée, que c'est l'Europe qui
permet de défendre notre
souveraineté alimentaire et nos
agriculteurs, que c'est l'Europe
qui nous permet de soutenir notre
économie.
L'Union Européenne devient une
puissance.
Nous pouvons être fiers du chemin
parcouru.
Sous l'égide du président de la
République, la France prend toute
sa part dans ce combat.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
je ne dis pas que l'Europe est
parfaite.
Les défis qui nous attendent sont
immenses.
Mais pour atteindre l'autonomie
stratégique et pour garantir notre
souveraineté et notre
indépendance, pour atteindre
la neutralité carbone,
nous avons besoin de l'Europe.
En ce 9 mai, face aux extrêmes et
aux populistes, nous continuerons
à les défendre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Bex pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Christophe Bex: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, chers
collègues, depuis des mois, le
peuple se mobilise contre votre
réforme des retraites injuste et
inutile.
Des millions de personnes
manifestent leur opposition chaque
journée de mobilisation.
93% des actifs de ce pays
expriment leur opposition.
Votre seule réponse est le mépris
et la répression.
Vous interdisez les dispositifs
sonores portatifs, sans avoir peur
du ridicule, ou les cartons rouges
au Stade de France.
Madame la Première ministre, la
page n'est pas tournée.
Votre projet brise des vies.
Il n'aura pas fallu attendre trois
semaines après sa promulgation
pour que votre contre-réforme des
retraites ait des conséquences
dramatiques.
Je pense en particulier à ces
femmes, à ces hommes qui avaient
négocié leur départ à la retraite
anticipée avec leurs employeurs.
Ils attendaient ce droit au repos.
C'est le cas d'Olivier, qui avait
prévu son départ à la retraite.
Il avait des projets tout tracés.
Il devra choisir entre prendre un
congé sans solde, le privant de
revenus, ou revenir travailler
durant une année.
Choisir entre revenir travailler
ou voir son revenu baisser, voilà
le progrès que vous réservez à nos
concitoyens.
Vous demeurez sourds aux
revendications d'un peuple que
vous traitez avec une arrogance
rarement atteinte.
Chers collègues, il est encore
temps d'agir et de mettre un
carton rouge à ce gouvernement!
Ce gouvernement cherche à étouffer
la contestation.
La page n'est pas tournée, madame
la Première ministre!
Le 8 juin prochain, votons la loi
d'abrogation!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt, ministre du Travail, du
Plein emploi et de l'Insertion.
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous évoquez
des sujets que je n'ignore pas.
Il faut rappeler quelques
réalités.
Aucun retraité parti à la retraite
ne sera jamais rappelé.
Deuxième chose, aucun individu
pouvant faire valoir son départ à
la retraite avant le 1er septembre
2023 ne peut être concerné par un
quelconque rappel que ce soit.
Les cas que vous évoquez sont au
nombre de 16 personnes.
Ces personnes ne sont pas à la
retraite, mais en congés.
Avec leur direction, elles avaient
négocié le solde de contrat
épargne temps ou de congés
anticipés.
Ce ne sont en aucun cas des
retraites.
Mon cabinet est en lien avec
chacune des sociétés évoquées.
Permettez-moi de vous dire que,
quand vous voulez parler au nom du
peuple et au nom des opposants,
avec La France Insoumise, ils ont
de mauvais porte-parole.
Vous n'avez servi à rien dans ce
débat.
Vous n'avez pas défendu les
salariés.
Vous avez voulu bloquer le débat.
Vous n'avez rien apporté.
Votre seule fonction est de mettre
le bazar ici et dans la rue.
Peut-être que vous êtes fier de
ceux qui appellent à décapiter le
président de la République.
Ce n'est pas notre conception de
la République.
la démocratie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Pieyre-Alexandre Anglade
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Pieyre-Alexandre Anglade: Madame
la Première ministre, nous
célébrons aujourd'hui la journée
de l'Europe et le discours
fondateur de Robert Schuman.
Depuis six ans, nous portons une
exigence de refondation du projet
européen.
Durant ces six années, nous avons
avancé sur ce chemin du plan de
relance européen à l'acquisition
des vaccins.
Nous avons eu une réponse commune
face à l'invasion russe en
Ukraine.
L'Europe a donc montré sa capacité
à résister, à protéger et à
dépasser ses dogmes.
Nous avons besoin de continuer à
transformer l'Europe de la
coopération en Europe de la
puissance.
Nous sommes à ce moment charnière
de notre histoire où nous devons
nous projeter dans l'avenir du
modèle européen et de son
autonomie stratégique.
Nous sommes dans un temps où les
menaces géopolitiques, l'urgence
climatique et les évolutions
technologiques majeures donnent à
l'Europe une responsabilité
particulière.
Nous sommes aussi dans un temps où
les ennemis de l'Europe restent
nombreux, y compris dans cet
hémicycle, où certains préfèrent
dépenser toute leur énergie pour
dénigrer le drapeau européen et
l'unité européenne.
Cela se passe à l'extrême droite
et à l'extrême gauche.
L'Europe est le meilleur levier de
protection.
Le 9 mai 2022, le président de la
République parlait à la conférence
sur l'avenir de l'Europe.
Ce sont les états généraux
de l'Europe.
Ils sont essentiels si nous
voulons répondre aux enjeux
de notre époque.
Dans ce siècle redevenu incertain,
nous voulons continuer à faire
de l'Europe un continent écologique,
le continent le plus protecteur
et celui qui défend les valeurs
de liberté et de démocratie.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer
la feuille de route du gouvernement
pour y parvenir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le président
Pieyre-Alexandre Anglade, il y a
73 ans, Robert Schuman a posé les
fondements de notre construction
européenne.
Sa déclaration, c'était d'abord
une promesse de paix.
Le retour de la guerre en Europe
rappelle que l'Union Européenne
nous apporte une protection
au quotidien.
C'est mon premier message
pour notre jeunesse.
Mon deuxième message, c'est que
l'Europe est devenue synonyme
d'action et de solutions au
service des peuples et au service
des Français.
C'est tout le sens de l'engagement
du président de la République
depuis 2017.
On disait l'Europe fragile face
aux crises.
C'est grâce à l'Europe que nous
avons pu mutualiser l'achat de
vaccins et relancer massivement
nos économies.
On la disait naïve sur le plan
commercial.
Elle a su imposer que les produits
importés respectent les mêmes
règles environnementales que les
produits internes.
On disait qu'elle était un marché.
L'Europe devient aujourd'hui une
puissance qui défend ses intérêts
et veut conquérir son
indépendance, avec un agenda
d'autonomie stratégique pour les
matières premières.
C'est une puissance qui promeut
ses valeurs en luttant contre le
travail forcé, contre les produits
issus de la déforestation ou pour
la régulation du numérique.
Une puissance sociale qui promeut
l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes et impose à chaque pays de
se doter d'un salaire minimum.
Enfin, l'Europe devient une
puissance géopolitique en
réagissant de manière unanime face
à la Russie, en finançant la
livraison d'armes pour aider
l'Ukraine, en renforçant sa
sécurité et sa défense.
Je n'ignore rien des défis qui
restent à relever, qu'il s'agisse
des migrations et des futurs
élargissements.
Nous sommes lucides sur le chemin
qui reste à parcourir.
Face aux cyniques qui lui prêtent
tous les maux j'assume de dire que
l'Europe est l'un des projets les
plus importants.
J'assume de dire que la
souveraineté nationale et la
souveraineté européenne se
renforcent mutuellement.
Sans Europe forte, nos nations ne
seront que plus faibles.
Notre famille politique est la
seule à être vraiment
pro-européenne.
Je le revendique, entre les
extrêmes et nous, il y aura
toujours l'Europe.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
en ce 9 mai, je souhaite à tous
nos compatriotes une belle fête de
l'Europe, en leur rappelant que
l'Europe est un combat.
La majorité présidentielle est
décidée à le mener.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Francesca
Pasquini pour le groupe
écologiste.
- Francesca Pasquini: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Samedi, des croix celtiques des
nationalistes révolutionnaires,
des cagoules et des marches noires
ont défilé à Paris sous la
bannière du Comité du 9 Mai en
hommage à un militant pétainiste
décédé en 94.
Je souhaiterais faire remarquer la
présence dans ce cortège de
l'ancien trésorier du parti de
madame Le Pen.
On ne masque pas ses origines si
facilement.
Cette manifestation n'a pas été
interdite, car elle ne constituait
pas "un risque de trouble à
l'ordre public".
Elle a été autorisée et encadrée
par la police.
Ce n'est pas parce que l'ennemi
est silencieux et marche au pas
qu'il n'est pas dangereux.
Comment célébrer le 8 mai 45 sans
dénoncer la violence intrinsèque
de ces groupes d'extrême droite?
Il est inconcevable que l'Etat ne
les considère pas comme un trouble
à l'ordre public.
Il y avait pourtant fondement à
interdire ce cortège.
Je vais vous dire sur quelle base.
"Le fascisme n'est pas une opinion
mais un crime."
Bien que ces manifestants aient
caché leur identité, nous ne
sommes pas dupes.
Vous préférez vous en prendre à
ceux qui battent le pavé à visage
découvert pour défendre leurs
droits à la retraite et à la
démocratie plutôt qu'à des
néonazis.
Ma question est la suivante:
monsieur le ministre,
entendez-vous le vol noir des
corbeaux sur nos plaines?
Entendez-vous les cris sourds du
pays qu'on enchaîne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée, ce qui s'est
passé dans les rues de Paris pour
cette manifestation est évidemment
inacceptable.
La Première ministre a une raison
de dire que ces manifestants
étaient un choc pour la
République.
Je voudrais vous dire que cette
demande de manifestation n'a pas
été déposée par un collectif mais
par un individu isolé.
En janvier dernier, nous avons
souhaité interdire cette
manifestation mais le tribunal
administratif de Paris nous a
sommés de pouvoir la laisser
s'organiser.
Cette manifestation ne présentait
pas, a priori, des difficultés qui
nous permettaient de l'interdire.
Ceci étant dit, vu ce qui s'est
passé dans les rues de Paris, j'ai
donné comme instruction au préfet
de police que tout militant
d'extrême droite, ou toute
association ou collectif qui
voudra tenir une manifestation
dans ce se verra prendre un arrêté
d'interdiction
par le préfet de police.
Je veux dire par ailleurs que,
s'il y a eu des agressions qui ont
été commises, je vous encourage à
faire déposer des plaintes le plus
rapidement possible pour que la
police puisse faire des enquêtes.
C'est bien notre gouvernement qui
a dissous des groupes d'extrême
droite qui étaient parfois là
depuis plus de 30 ans sur le
territoire national.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Elsa
Faucillon pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine.
- Elsa Faucillon: Merci.
Votre opération "Tourner la page"
est un fiasco.
Vos tentatives de diversion ne
peuvent effacer votre passage en
force, s'agissant d'une réforme
qui abîme si durement et si
concrètement la vie des gens.
Les premières victimes sont bien
réelles.
Ce sont ces femmes et ces hommes
qui après toute une vie
professionnelle, avaient planifié
leur départ en retraite.
Ils étaient en congé de fin de
carrière car leur projet était
bien de partir en retraite.
Ils sont aujourd'hui contraints de
revenir au travail.
Pour faire la jonction avec leurs
nouvelles dates de départ à la
retraite, il leur est proposé de
prendre un congé sans solde
ou de reprendre leur emploi.
Vous savez bien qu'il n'y aura pas
que ces 16 salariés.
Ce sont des milliers de femmes
et d'hommes suspendus
à la publication des décrets
d'application pour déterminer
s'ils devront ou non retirer leur
demande de départ à la retraite
ou consentir à une décote
de leur pension.
Ce sont ces travailleurs
et travailleuses venus du Maghreb ou
d'Afrique subsaharienne qui
occupent les métiers les plus
pénibles et qui ont des retraites
de misère à cause de carrières
hachées faites d'intérim et des
périodes mal ou non déclarées par
leurs employeurs.
Ils découvrent qu'il leur faudra
rester neuf mois en France et non
plus six pour bénéficier de la
retraite.
Du jour au lendemain, ce sont des
projets de vie que vous volez.
Vu le précédent sur les carrières
longues et sur les 1200 euros,
permettez-nous d'y voir
un mensonge de plus.
C'est une marque de mépris
supplémentaire.
Votre réforme nous réserve encore
beaucoup trop de mauvaises
surprises.
Nous ne tournons pas la page.
Elle ne se tourne pas comme ça.
Nous serons bien sûr au
rendez-vous du 6 juin dans la rue.
Le 8 juin aussi, nous serons ici
aussi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame
la députée, vous avez évoqué la
réponse que j'ai donnée.
Aucun retraité n'est rappelé.
Certains salariés ont aujourd'hui
un âge de départ qui va être
décalé de trois mois.
Nous sommes en contact avec
chacune des sociétés concernées.
Nous travaillons en lien avec les
équipes de la Première ministre
pour convaincre les entreprises
concernées qu'elles peuvent
accompagner les personnes.
Nous faisons en sorte que personne
ne revienne travailler.
Le nombre de cas global ne sera
pas élevé.
D'abord, c'est parce que pour
bénéficier d'un congé de fin de
carrière, c'est quand même une
situation rare...
C'est plutôt le cas dans de très
grandes entreprises.
Nous assurons ce suivi avec la
plus grande attention.
Vous parliez ensuite des décrets
d'application.
Cela a été transmis
aux caisses de retraite.
Ils sont conformes à la loi.
On peut s'appuyer sur la loi et
sur l'ensemble des documents.
Les décrets sont parfaitement
conformes.
Ils concernent l'âge et la
revalorisation des retraites.
Le 1er septembre n'est pas
seulement une question d'âge.
- Guillaume Gouffier Valente:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Préalablement à ma question, en
cette journée de l'Europe, je
tiens à affirmer au nom du groupe
Renaissance notre soutien aux
femmes et aux hommes qui se
battent pour la défense du droit à
l'avortement.
Madame la ministre, depuis
plusieurs semaines, le
gouvernement est interpellé sur
les tensions d'approvisionnement
d'une molécule indispensable pour
organiser les IVG.
Il y a plusieurs médicaments
qui possèdent cette molécule.
Si nous ne pouvons pas parler de
pénurie, puisque des stocks
existent dans tous les centres et
établissements de santé,
ces tensions interrogent
et inquiètent.
Pouvez-vous nous dire les raisons
de ces difficultés?
En outre, alors même que le droit
à l'avortement est aujourd'hui
attaqué de manière organisée et
régulière par les mouvements
conservateurs et d'extrême droite
partout à travers le monde, y
compris en Europe et en France,
nous nous devons d'entendre les
inquiétudes plus globales
que révèle l'interpellation
de ces dernières semaines.
Cet épisode vient nous rappeler
l'enjeu majeur de l'IVG légale
et libre d'accès
à toutes les femmes.
Cet enjeu, nous le soulevions déjà
avec la délégation en mars et en
novembre 2022.
Cet enjeu est majeur pour notre
groupe.
En 2023, il n'est pas acceptable
que des femmes qui souhaitent
avorter rencontrent des
difficultés, voire renoncent.
Quelles sont les mesures mises en
place par le gouvernement pour
garantir l'accès à toutes les
femmes à l'IVG?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Je vous
prie d'excuser l'absence du
ministre François Braun, retenu au
Sénat cet après-midi.
Permettez-moi tout d'abord d'avoir
une pensée pour Simone Veil, qui
a fait de cette question le coeur de
son engagement politique.
Les difficultés que vous évoquez
concernent le misoprostol.
Il y a un dysfonctionnement dans
la chaîne de production
de certains médicaments qui
contiennent cette molécule.
Le ministre s'est assuré que
toutes les mesures avaient été
prises pour garantir son accès aux
centres IVG.
Des livraisons de 46.500 boîtes,
couvrant plus de trois mois
de consommation, ont débuté
depuis le 7 avril dernier.
Ces livraisons ont permis
d'honorer les reliquats
de commande.
Les 40.500 boîtes restantes
assurent une couverture large des
besoins dans les prochaines
semaines, en attente de la
prochaine livraison.
Nous pouvons garantir une
distribution plus régulière.
Concernant la spécialité dont vous
parliez, les besoins mensuels sont
couverts, mais des tensions
subsistent pour les boîtes de un
comprimé.
Depuis fin avril, 45.000 boîtes
sont en cours de livraison,
ce qui permettra de normaliser
la situation.
Afin de consolider la situation,
des circuits ville-hôpital
ont été mis en place.
Nous suivons avec attention
la situation.
Vous pouvez compter sur notre
engagement et celui de l'ensemble
du gouvernement pour garantir
l'accès à l'IVG à toutes les
femmes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Alexis Corbière.
- Alexis Corbière: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Education nationale,
jeudi 4 mai, le président de la
République a annoncé un profond
bouleversement de l'enseignement
professionnel.
Il a déclaré: "Ce n'est pas
seulement une réforme, c'est une
cause nationale."
Certes, l'enseignement
professionnel le mériterait, mais
votre projet n'est pas une cause,
mais une casse nationale.
Si on vous laisse faire, vous
allez briser la spécificité de
notre enseignement professionnel
qui, malgré les difficultés,
mérite beaucoup plus que cela.
Vos annonces manifestent une
méconnaissance totale de la
réalité.
Dans beaucoup de médias, vous avez
annoncé que la philosophie de
votre réforme, c'est rapprocher le
lycée professionnel du monde de
l'entreprise, mais c'est déjà le
cas.
Tous les diplômes de
l'enseignement professionnel sont
définis dans des commissions en
présence de branches patronales.
Pourquoi faire croire le
contraire?
Dans quel but?
Tous les élèves de terminale ont
déjà huit semaines de stage, et
vous proposez d'en rajouter 50%,
sans la moindre justification
pédagogique.
Vous savez qu'aujourd'hui, 3
élèves sur 4 vont jusqu'au bac
quand c'est seulement 2 sur 5 qui
y arrivent dans l'apprentissage.
Vous annoncez des bureaux
d'entreprises dans les lycées
professionnels.
Cela ne servira qu'à répondre aux
besoins immédiats du patronat.
Vous proposez une rémunération
pour les enseignants, mais vous
n'êtes que dans le slogan éculé de
Sarkozy: "Travailler plus pour
gagner plus".
Bref, nous ne vous laisserons pas
faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, cher
collègue.
La parole est à madame Carole
Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député, l'enseignement
professionnel doit d'abord être
crédible dans les entreprises pour
déboucher sur des emplois.
Ce n'est pas une citation de la
majorité, mais une citation de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon, alors ministre
de l'Enseignement professionnel en
2000.
En fait, ce qu'il n'a pas fait,
nous allons le faire.
Notre ambition est claire: faire
de la voie professionnelle une
voie d'excellence.
Pour cela, nous allons rapprocher
l'école de l'entreprise.
La voie professionnelle doit être
professionnalisante.
Elle doit ouvrir des opportunités.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: On écoute
madame la ministre!
- Carole Grandjean: Nous allons
réparer la méconnaissance des
entreprises, accentuer le manque
de réseau professionnel des
jeunes, qui est un obstacle majeur
dans l'accès au premier emploi.
Nous allons y mettre les moyens,
ce qu'il faudra faire pour
accompagner les élèves.
C'est notamment la gratification
des périodes de formation en
milieu professionnel, mais
également l'augmentation du nombre
de semaines de stage, avec un
montant de gratification qui ira
de 600 à 1200 euros pour certains
élèves en terminale.
Cette mesure, monsieur Mélenchon
l'a proposée lorsqu'il était
ministre.
S'il avait mis autant de fougue
dans les lycées professionnels que
dans les vaines polémiques, nous
serions peut-être avancés.
Aujourd'hui, Emmanuel Macron
l'avait annoncé et il le fait.
Ce ne sera pas la déscolarisation
des jeunes pour autant, au
contraire.
Les matières fondamentales seront
renforcées dès cette rentrée 2023,
grâce notamment à la proposition
qui permet de mieux
les accompagner en mathématiques
et en français.
Nous ne nous satisfaisons pas du
statu quo qui conduit nos jeunes
à l'échec.
Nous portons une réforme
ambitieuse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Marietta
Karamanli.
- Marietta Karamanli: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
L'inflation devrait rester élevée
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2023
dans notre pays,
entre 5,5 et 6,5%.
Cette forte hausse des prix
à la consommation va affecter le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages
et la croissance du PIB français.
Le gouvernement prédisait il y a
deux mois une baisse d'ici l'été.
Nous n'y serons pas.
En mars, un institut de
statistiques économiques a fait
état d'une augmentation de près
de 15% des prix alimentaires
sur 12 mois.
Les mesures qui ont été prises
sont loin du compte.
L'accès aux biens de première
nécessité devient très difficile
pour les plus modestes.
Les petits salaires juste
au-dessus du SMIC n'ont aucune
perspective d'évolution.
Les retraites de base ont augmenté
de 0,8% au 1er janvier 2023, mais
l'inflation a augmenté
de plus de 5% l'année passée!
La facture énergétique est encore
plus forte dans de nombreux
territoires ruraux et périurbains.
Les logements sont moins isolés et
plus énergivores.
Si MaPrimeRénov' s'est transformée
en galère avec des travaux à payer
sans versement rapide des primes,
alors que l'on peinait à taxer
les superprofits, alors que de
nombreux économistes plaident pour
faire contribuer les hyperriches
qui n'ont un taux d'imposition
effectif que de 2%, vous refusez
pour des raisons d'idéaux.
Des propositions existent.
La baisse des taxes sur l'énergie,
les négociations salariales
pour accélérer l'augmentation
des salaires les plus modestes, de
nouvelles mesures en matière
d'accès à la rénovation
énergétique...
Qu'allez-vous faire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole
est à monsieur...
Olivier Dussopt?
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, permettez-moi
de vous répondre comme ancien
ministre des Comptes publics et
comme ministre du Travail.
Si votre groupe avait voté toutes
les mesures de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat, votre critique serait un
peu plus fondée.
Nous sommes le gouvernement qui a
mis en place le plus de mesures de
lutte contre l'inflation,
d'accompagnement des ménages,
notamment pour la prise en charge
des factures énergétiques, des
mesures aussi pour faire en sorte
que face à cette inflation, le
partage de la valeur soit au
rendez-vous.
Je prendrai deux exemples.
D'abord, nous avons mis en oeuvre
les revalorisations du SMIC.
Nous voulons que le comité de
suivi des négociations salariales
puisse être pleinement actif, de
manière à ce que chaque fois
qu'une branche voit un niveau
passer en dessous du SMIC, le
dialogue social puisse être
relancé.
Nous aurons l'occasion de
soumettre à l'Assemblée un projet
de loi permettant de transposer
dans la loi l'accord national
interprofessionnel en matière de
partage de la valeur, permettant
d'avancer en matière
d'intéressement
et de participation dans les
entreprises, d'avancer aussi dans
le cadre des entreprises qui
réalisent des résultats
exceptionnels pour qu'elles
puissent verser un intéressement
tout aussi exceptionnel.
A chaque fois, nous serons au
rendez-vous.
J'espère que vous le serez aussi,
cette fois-ci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Alexandra Masson.
- Alexandra Masson: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur, le 5 mai
dernier, un migrant guinéen
lançait en direct sur BFM TV: "On
va vous envahir."
Il était au poste-frontière de
Menton, dans ma circonscription,
quelques minutes après que j'ai
constaté que celui-ci ne faisait
l'objet d'aucun contrôle de police
et ce malgré vos annonces de
renforts.
Deux jours plus tôt, avec Jordan
Bardella et mes collègues, nous
avons pu constater que les
effectifs de la police aux
frontières étaient largement
insuffisants face à la vague
migratoire, qui a quadruplé en
moins d'un an.
En réponse à cette déferlante,
vous n'avez rien trouvé de mieux
que de traiter la cheffe du
gouvernement italien d'incapable.
Comme vous n'êtes pas à un
paradoxe près, en novembre, c'est
l'inverse.
Giorgia Meloni était inhumaine et
irresponsable en refusant
d'accueillir des migrants.
Vos propos et vos actions sont
désastreux.
Vos déclarations sont
irresponsables.
Au moment où nos deux pays doivent
être partenaires, vous avez
affaibli l'image de la France en
Italie.
Allez-vous présenter vos excuses à
l'Italie et allez-vous enfin
prendre vos responsabilités et
installer de manière pérenne des
effectifs à cette frontière?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
députée, vous l'avez dit, depuis
le 1er janvier, c'est 42.200
personnes qui se sont présentées
en 2023 venant d'Italie,
c'est-à-dire quatre fois plus en
un an.
Vous auriez pu remercier les
forces de l'ordre, puisque c'est
80% de refoulement à la frontière
de plus par nos forces de l'ordre.
Je voudrais les remercier.
Vous avez le droit de ne pas
soutenir les forces de l'ordre.
Ne vous énervez pas comme ça.
Huées
Je veux vous dire qu'il faudrait
que tous les pays européens se
mettent d'accord pour qu'il y ait
des contrôles externes aux
frontières de l'Europe, ce que
l'on appelle l'enregistrement pour
pouvoir refouler les personnes aux
frontières de l'Europe.
Il faudrait aussi qu'une procédure
d'asile unique soit mise en place.
C'est vrai qu'il faudrait revoir
totalement le règlement.
Au Parlement européen, vous faites
l'inverse.
Monsieur Bardella a voté contre le
mandat de négociation pour que ces
problèmes soient résolus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Alexandra Masson: Monsieur
Darmanin, les forces de l'ordre,
comme je le dis régulièrement, je
les soutiens beaucoup plus que
vous.
Moi, je suis régulièrement au
poste-frontière.
Ce que vous oubliez de dire, c'est
qu'en ne réglant pas le problème
migratoire, vous les mettez en
danger tous les jours.
Il y a des accidents
régulièrement.
Les forces de l'ordre souffrent
beaucoup plus que ce que vous ne
le pensez.
Arrêtez d'être incompétent et
venez régler le problème.
- Gérald Darmanin: Je constate
qu'il a fallu que je fasse la
remarque pour que vous souteniez
les policiers.
C'est un progrès.
Vous ne devez pas être souvent
dans votre circonscription.
280 CRS sont arrivés dans votre
circonscription.
Normalement, ça se voit, si vous
allez les rencontrer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Carel.
- Agnès Carel: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
Le pouvoir d'achat reste la
préoccupation majeure des
Français.
L'inflation touche de plein fouet
la majorité de nos concitoyens.
Malgré la hausse du SMIC de ce 1er
mai, les bas salaires se voient
rattrapés par ceux qui touchent le
SMIC.
Les difficultés pour boucler les
fins de mois sont le lot commun de
beaucoup de nos administrés.
Les augmentations de prix dans
l'alimentation sont sans fin.
15,8% de hausse sur un an, en
mars.
Pourtant, le coût de l'énergie a
baissé, celui du transport aussi.
Ce constat s'applique aussi pour
la plupart des matières premières,
mais cela ne se traduit pas à la
pompe pour nos concitoyens, malgré
la baisse significative du prix du
baril.
Certes, en France, les prix ne
sont pas recalculés
automatiquement.
Il y a des négociations une fois
par an.
Concrètement, les industriels et
les distributeurs semblent
profiter de cette situation.
Vous avez demandé aux industriels
de l'agroalimentaire et à la
grande distribution de nouvelles
négociations commerciales pour
faire baisser les prix dans les
magasins.
Le gouvernement souhaite qu'après
l'Etat et les distributeurs qui
ont fait des efforts avec le
trimestre anti-inflation, ce soit
au tour des industriels de
l'agroalimentaire de prendre leur
part pour répercuter la baisse des
coûts de certaines matières
premières.
Vous espérez une baisse visible
des prix à la rentrée de septembre
grâce à cette réouverture des
négociations, mais les Français
attendent la rentrée, et la
rentrée leur semble beaucoup trop
lointaine.
Pouvez-vous nous faire un point
sur ces avancées et rassurer nos
concitoyens?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
députée, il y a un an, les grands
industriels étaient venus nous
voir, avec Olivia Grégoire, avec
le ministre de l'Industrie Roland
Lescure, en nous disant que les
prix du fret maritime étaient en
train de flamber.
Ils étaient passés à 15.000 euros
le container.
Les prix du blé étaient en train
de flamber.
Les prix du pétrole aussi.
Il fallait pouvoir répercuter
cette augmentation sur les prix de
détail, sinon, les industries
allaient être menacées.
Nous leur avons répondu et nous
leur avons permis d'indexer
l'augmentation des prix de gros
sur les prix de détail.
Nous l'avons fait tout de suite
pour protéger nos industriels et
protéger nos emplois.
Aujourd'hui, les prix de gros sont
en train de baisser.
Les prix du blé sont en train de
baisser.
Les prix du brut sont également
très faibles.
Les industriels doivent sans délai
répercuter cette baisse des prix
de gros sur les prix de détail
pour protéger nos compatriotes
contre l'augmentation des prix
alimentaires, qui est
insupportable.
Je verrai cette semaine les
distributeurs pour examiner avec
eux comment ils peuvent prolonger
le trimestre anti-inflation
au-delà du 15 juin.
La semaine prochaine, je réunirai
tous les industriels, notamment
ceux de l'agroalimentaire, mais
pas uniquement, pour leur demander
de répercuter sans délai dans les
négociations commerciales la
baisse des prix de gros sur les
prix de détail pour protéger nos
compatriotes contre cette spirale
inflationniste qui est
insupportable.
Soit ils acceptent de rentrer dans
le jeu des négociations et de
répercuter à la baisse les prix de
gros sur les prix de détail, soit
nous ne voyons aucun mouvement et
nous nous réservons le droit
d'utiliser tous les moyens à notre
disposition pour que ces prix
baissent et que nos compatriotes
payent leurs produits alimentaires
moins cher.
- Agnès Carel: On compte sur vous,
monsieur le ministre.
Il faut redonner du pouvoir
d'achat.
Les Français nous attendent.
Ces signaux les remettraient en
confiance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Estelle
Youssouffa.
- Estelle Youssouffa: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Alors que la police et la
gendarmerie multiplient les
arrestations d'envergure sur le
terrain, la mobilisation de
Mayotte pour soutenir l'opération
Wuambushu ne faiblit pas.
Des milliers de nos compatriotes
ont encore défilé ce week-end dans
le nord de l'île, mais aussi à
Marseille, entre autres.
Cette extraordinaire mobilisation
citoyenne traduit notre aspiration
à vivre en sécurité.
Notre reconnaissance pour les
efforts déployés également.
Cette mobilisation traduit aussi
notre gratitude pour l'écoute et
la solidarité pour Mayotte
exprimée ici, au-delà des clivages
partisans, mais aussi dans les
médias et lors des manifestations.
Etre enfin entendus, que nos
compatriotes nous comprennent,
cela nous redonne espoir pour
l'avenir de Mayotte, et pour cela,
nous vous disons merci, ici, à
tous.
Cette mobilisation citoyenne porte
la dignité et le courage d'un
peuple face aux mensonges du
président comorien qui encourage
implicitement la terreur.
Il se permet ici, à Paris, de
faire la leçon à la France et de
bloquer l'un des volets de
l'opération Wuambushu en refusant
de prendre ses ressortissants en
situation irrégulière.
Azali Assoumani s'est entretenu
hier à l'Elysée avec Emmanuel
Macron.
Ces négociations ont-elles abouti?
Les Comores vont-elles enfin
permettre les reconduites à la
frontière?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Madame la députée, merci de votre
soutien à l'action du
gouvernement, mais surtout des
femmes et des hommes de l'Etat
et des forces de l'ordre,
sous l'égide du préfet.
Depuis que cette opération a été
déclenchée, 134 interpellations
ont eu lieu.
Un tiers des bandes criminelles
que nous avons dans le viseur de
la justice ont été interpellées
sur le territoire de Mayotte,
rendant ainsi très concret le
travail annoncé par l'action
voulue par le président de la
République.
Des destructions d'habitats
illégaux, des interpellations de
fauteurs de troubles et des
reconduites à la frontière pour
plusieurs pays, notamment le Sri
Lanka, Madagascar et les Comores.
Depuis une dizaine de jours, les
zones maritimes avec les Comores
sont arrêtées.
Nous avons, avec la ministre des
Affaires étrangères, rencontré nos
homologues.
Le communiqué commun est sorti à
15h.
Les deux délégations ont réaffirmé
leur volonté de lutter contre les
passeurs, y compris par la reprise
des liaisons maritimes.
Les liaisons maritimes entre les
Comores et Mayotte vont reprendre
grâce à l'action du président de
la République, qui a reçu le
président Azali Assoumani hier.
Le travail va pouvoir continuer.
Les policiers et les gendarmes
font tous les jours ce qu'aucun
autre gouvernement n'a fait pour
Mayotte.
Je veux dire aux Mahorais que de
Mayotte, nous entendons leur
soutien.
Nous les remercions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Jean-Philippe
Nilor.
- Jean-Philippe Nilor: Madame la
Première ministre, à la veille de
la commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavage, une nouvelle forme de
servitude s'abat de plein fouet
sur les populations ultramarines
dont la mobilité est forcément
captive.
Pour le seul mois de mars, le coût
du billet d'avion a augmenté de
plus de 50% en Martinique et en
Guadeloupe.
Entre le 1er et le 25 août, il
faudra débourser 2231 euros pour
un Paris-Fort-de-France, contre
1037 euros pour un Paris-Miami.
La flambée du cours du kérosène
n'explique pas une telle
différence de prix pour des durées
de vol équivalentes.
Les tarifs abusifs imposés par des
compagnies aériennes vis-à-vis de
peuples qui plient déjà sous la
vie chère constituent un véritable
scandale.
Depuis 1976, l'Etat a doté la
Corse d'une délégation de service
public.
Il y dépense aujourd'hui 220
millions d'euros, ce qui nous
réjouit, mais seulement 45
millions d'euros pour l'ensemble
des territoires d'outre-mer, ce
qui nous révolte.
Madame la Première ministre, au
nom du principe d'égalité, quand
adopterez-vous enfin, dans les
territoires d'outre-mer, une vraie
politique de continuité
territoriale, dotée de vrais
moyens budgétaires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, je vous prie
d'excuser Jean-François Carenco,
actuellement à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon, mais
j'ai échangé avec lui ce matin.
Il veut vous dire que nous avons
tout à fait conscience de
l'augmentation des prix.
Si les prix ont augmenté de 50%,
Jean-François Carenco a
rendez-vous avec Bruno Le Maire
dans les prochains jours pour
évoquer ce sujet, ainsi que la
continuité territoriale.
Il vous recevra avec Clément
Beaune à la fin de cette semaine,
si vous le souhaitez.
Je me permets de vous dire que les
collectivités locales ont aussi
une possibilité qu'ils n'ont pas
utilisée jusqu'à présent, c'est de
contribuer à cet effort
supplémentaire pour que nos
concitoyens ultramarins voient des
prix moins chers.
C'est une vraie question que vous
posez, bien sûr.
L'Etat a apporté une première
réponse d'augmentation de sa prise
en charge.
Il faut désormais que nous aidions
davantage encore nos compatriotes.
- Jean-Philippe Nilor: Je suis
désolé, mais je vous parle de prix
de transport aérien, et on dirait
que vous voulez me mener en
bateau.
Dans tous nos outre-mer, la colère
gronde et les gens ont de plus en
plus le sentiment de se faire
racketter par les compagnies
aériennes organisées en oligopoles
sous le regard complice de l'Etat
et de la Commission européenne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Matthieu Marchio.
- Matthieu Marchio: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire, ministre de
l'Economie.
La colère des Français contre la
réforme des retraites ne retombe
pas.
La hausse des prix est durement
ressentie par les classes
populaires, celle-là même que vous
assommez un peu plus en les
condamnant à trimer un peu plus
longtemps au chômage et au travail
avant de gagner une retraite qui
ne leur permettra même pas de
boucler les fins de mois.
On leur avait promis une retraite
minimum à 1200 euros.
Ce ne sont pas des mesures que
vous annoncez qui viendront faire
oublier vos perfidies.
Distribuer des chèques qui ne sont
en rien une réponse durable aux
besoins des Français ne sert à
rien.
Votre politique gouvernementale
est l'archétype d'une déconnexion
profonde.
Alors que les Français peinent à
faire le plein de leurs véhicules
et à en assurer l'entretien, vous
faites la promotion d'un plan vélo
à 2 milliards d'euros.
Monsieur le ministre, allez donc
dire aux salariés du bassin minier
d'aller prendre leur vélo pour
aller travailler.
Vous n'avez rien compris
aux priorités des travailleurs.
Je vais vous prendre au mot.
Vous nous reprochez de citer
Marine Le Pen.
Sa popularité vous dérange.
Je vais citer du Emmanuel Macron.
"Pour les gens qui ne sont rien,
le mépris social,
vous l'arrêtez quand?"
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire, ministre de l'Economie, des
Finances, de la souveraineté
numérique.
- Bruno Le Maire: Monsieur
le député Marchio, ce sont
les solutions du Rassemblement
National qui sont déconnectées de
la réalité.
Si nous avions suivi depuis
quelques années les solutions
du Rassemblement National et de
Marine Le Pen, pour faire face aux
problèmes des Français, qu'est-ce
que cela aurait donné?
Nous aurions un retour à la
retraite à 60 ans qui aurait ruiné
le système de retraite par
répartitions, nous serions sortis
de l'euro comme l'avait proposé
Marine Le Pen, alors que l'euro
nous a protégés face à la crise
du Covid et nous a permis d'émettre
de la dette en commun.
Nous aurions tous été soignés
à la chloroquine.
Je ne suis pas certain que la
santé des Français aurait été
meilleure.
Si nous avions suivi les solutions
de Marine Le Pen, nous serions
aujourd'hui du côté de la Russie
et pas de l'Ukraine, de
l'oppresseur et pas de la liberté,
de l'agresseur et pas du
résistant!
Voilà la réalité des propositions
de Marine Le Pen.
Sur l'inflation, quelle est la
seule proposition que vous ayez
portée?
Pas le plafonnement des prix de
l'électricité, pas l'indemnité
carburant ni la revalorisation des
minima sociaux.
Vous n'avez rien voté.
Vous n'avez rien voté de ce qui
protège aujourd'hui les Français
contre l'inflation.
Votre solution, c'est la baisse
de la TVA qui va engraisser les
distributeurs au lieu de protéger
les consommateurs
et nos compatriotes.
Les solutions du Front National
ne sont depuis 10 ans
que des illusions.
Nous proposons des solutions
concrètes et tangibles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Matthieu
Marchio.
- Matthieu Marchio: Il y a un an,
Emmanuel Macron avait entendu ce
que les gens pensent de leurs
projets.
Ils n'attendent toujours rien
de vous.
Vive l'alternance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Goetschy-Bolognese
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Charlotte Goetschy-Bolognese:
Merci.
Madame la ministre, la semaine
dernière, le président
de la République détaillait
les grands axes de la réforme
des lycées professionnels.
Lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire, insertion
professionnelle et revalorisation
du travail des enseignants.
Ces annonces sont cruciales car
elles concernent un très grand
nombre de lycéens de notre pays.
Chaque année, 1 collégien sur 3
s'oriente vers un lycée
professionnel, ce qui représente
621.000 élèves et 64.000
apprentis.
Des annonces importantes alors que
nous entrons dans l'année
européenne des compétences.
Elle devra notamment permettre une
meilleure mobilité internationale,
des apprentis par le programme
Erasmus+.
Pendant longtemps, les lycées
professionnels ont été
dévalorisés.
Il nous appartient de leur
redonner leur rayonnement.
A ce titre, nous ne pouvons que
nous réjouir des mesures
annoncées, que ce soit en adoptant
la terminale à chaque lycéen avec
une gratification des stages, ou
avec un renforcement du lien entre
lycées et entreprises.
Une main-d'oeuvre qualifiée est
synonyme d'emploi mieux rémunéré.
Il est primordial d'accompagner
nos jeunes vers les secteurs
d'avenir.
Aussi, pouvez-vous me préciser si
une réforme de la carte des
formations est envisagée tout en
tenant compte des spécificités de
chaque territoire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Carole
Grandjean, ministre déléguée
chargée de l'Enseignement et de la
Formation professionnelle.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Madame la députée, nous marquons
aujourd'hui, pour cette journée de
l'Europe, le lancement de l'année
européenne des compétences.
Cela suit l'année européenne de la
jeunesse.
Je voudrais replacer ce contexte
dans cette dynamique sur laquelle
la France est leader.
Il y a une augmentation de
l'apprentissage et la forte
mobilisation des comptes
personnels de formation, avec une
large popularisation de cet outil.
C'est aussi tout le sens que vient
prendre la réforme des lycées
professionnels que le président de
la République a présenté
la semaine dernière.
Cette réforme vise à lutter contre
le décrochage scolaire, trop
fréquent en lycée professionnel,
non pas du fait des lycées
professionnels et des personnels
éducatifs.
Cette fragilité existait
auparavant.
C'est pourquoi nous allons
travailler dès le primaire et le
collège sur le décrochage
scolaire, pour favoriser
l'insertion professionnelle et
la poursuite d'études réussies
de ces jeunes et pour valoriser
ces filières stratégiques.
C'est le changement d'image
que nous devons pouvoir opérer.
Cela passera par la réussite des
jeunes et par l'ouverture de
filières qui ouvrent de véritables
perspectives professionnelles à
venir.
C'est pour cela que, dès cette
rentrée prochaine, de nouvelles
formations seront ouvertes, avec
de nombreuses places dans
certaines filières.
Plus de 1000 places seront
ouvertes dès l'année prochaine
dans certaines filières.
Il y aura un travail sur
l'attractivité des filières dès
l'insertion et dès la découverte
des métiers.
Nous travaillerons là-dessus.
Nous avons des taux d'insertion
qui approchent les 10% sur
certaines formations.
C'est pour chaque territoire que
des formations pourront être
ouvertes ou pas.
Nous travaillerons là-dessus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Fabien
Roussel.
- Fabien Roussel: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Industrie, j'étais
ce matin avec une délégation
d'élus communistes à la rencontre
des salariés de l'entreprise
menacée par le départ de son
principal actionnaire chinois.
Cette entreprise est la seule et
l'unique entreprise française à
réaliser des roues, pour faire
rouler nos métros et nos tramways.
C'est la seule en France.
Le savoir-faire de ses 346
salariés est unique.
Nous avons besoin de ces deux
sites pour livrer le matériel
nécessaire à nos régions et à nos
entreprises publiques que sont la
RATP et la SNCF.
Cette entreprise a été livrée il y
a des années à des actionnaires
étrangers.
Ils s'en vont.
C'est l'occasion de reprendre la
main sur un outil stratégique
indispensable à notre filière
industrielle comme à la transition
écologique.
Il revient à la SNCF de faire
travailler la France plutôt
que d'autres pays.
La SNCF demandait encore il y a
10 ans 45.000 roues par an et 5000
essieux à cette entreprise.
L'an dernier, ce chiffre est tombé
à 3000 roues par an
et à 3 essieux.
L'Etat doit s'engager à travailler
d'abord avec cette entreprise
française plutôt que de profiter
de la concurrence libre.
Une heure de travail qui part en
Chine ou à l'étranger, c'est une
heure de chômage que nous payons
ici.
Il faut arrêter avec ça.
C'est ça qui tue notre industrie
et nos emplois.
Pour rendre compétitive cette
entreprise, il faut aussi investir
dans sa forge et lui garantir du
gaz et de l'électricité pas chers
et décarbonés.
C'est possible.
Il faut régler ce problème
énergétique.
Vous travaillez à un plan en
faveur de l'industrie verte.
Cette entreprise
doit en faire partie.
La BPI doit rentrer dans
le capital de l'entreprise pour lui
garantir son avenir et attirer
des investisseurs
et des industriels.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Roland Lescure,
ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure: Monsieur
le député Fabien Roussel, j'aimerais
d'abord reconnaître que vous êtes
déjà depuis de nombreuses semaines
aux côtés des salariés
de cette entreprise.
Vous m'avez déjà alerté sur cette
situation.
Je tiens à le souligner.
C'est une situation pas facile.
L'entreprise publique chinoise
avait repris l'entreprise et
l'avait fait en espérant pouvoir
vendre des roues en Chine.
Ca n'a pas été possible.
On a une entreprise qui est
aujourd'hui en surcapacité et qui
ne vend pas assez de roues en
France.
Il faut que l'on regarde de près
la situation, pour qu'on puisse à
court terme continuer l'activité
sur le site.
L'acier qui sert pour faire les
roues vient de Chine.
Il y a un risque d'arrêt de
l'approvisionnement.
Ca va être ma priorité
à court terme.
L'énergie de l'entreprise
vient d'Ascoval.
On a besoin que ce ne soit pas
trop cher.
A moyen terme, on va devoir
trouver un repreneur avec un outil
de travail qui est obsolète.
La forge a plus de 50 ans.
On avait besoin d'investissements.
On a aussi besoin de trouver de la
compétitivité.
On ne va pas nationaliser la
production de roues en France.
On doit trouver un investisseur
financier.
On suit de très près la situation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Virginie Duby-Muller
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Virginie Duby-Muller: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
des Armées. Le 4 avril dernier,
vous avez présenté
la loi de programmation
militaire pour 2024-2030.
Ce texte fixe les orientations de
notre politique de défense pour
les sept prochaines années.
Il consacre un budget de 413
milliards d'euros à nos armées,
soit 2,1% du PIB.
Cet effort budgétaire n'est pas un
luxe mais un impératif au regard
de la dégradation du contexte
géopolitique marqué par la guerre
en Ukraine ainsi que par
l'émergence de nouvelles menaces.
Terrorisme en Afrique,
prolifération nucléaire de la
Corée du Nord et de l'Iran, guerre
avec la Russie...
S'ajoutent aussi des sauts
technologiques continus dans les
domaines de la robotique,
des drones et de la technologie
quantique ou de l'intelligence
artificielle.
Dans ce monde chaque jour plus
dangereux, la guerre en Ukraine a
montré que la manière de faire la
guerre évolue aussi.
Outre les champs de conflictualité
traditionnelle, il faut ajouter
l'espace et les fonds marins.
La France ne peut pas ignorer ces
enjeux stratégiques si elle veut
assurer ses missions prioritaires
en matière de défense.
La LPM consacre des budgets
importants pour l'adaptation de
nos armées aux enjeux actuels.
On peut toutefois regretter que
ces investissements ne soient pas
au niveau de ceux réalisés par le
Royaume-Uni et l'Allemagne et que
ces efforts soient prévus après le
quinquennat Emmanuel Macron, alors
qu'il faudrait prévoir une montée
en puissance dès 2025.
La politique de défense est avant
tout une affaire humaine.
L'armée a besoin d'hommes et de
femmes prêts à s'engager pour leur
pays.
Pourriez-vous nous indiquer
comment vous comptez mettre les
ressources humaines des armées en
cohérence avec les ambitions
stratégiques de notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Patricia Mirallès, secrétaire
d'Etat chargée des Anciens
combattants et de la Mémoire.
- Patricia Mirallès: Madame la
députée, monsieur le ministre des
Armées, est en train de suivre la
situation en Guyane.
Des actions cybercriminels contre
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes, des
actions contre le groupe du Sénat,
des actions stratégiques provenant
d'Etats...
Sachez que la France prend déjà la
menace cyber très au sérieux.
Nous renforcerons leurs
prérogatives dans la prochaine loi
de programmation militaire.
D'autres ministères sont aussi
impliqués, notamment Bercy...
Notamment Bercy, le ministère de
la Justice, le ministère de
l'Intérieur et le Quai d'Orsay.
Le ministère des Armées développe
ses capacités pour garantir les
opérations militaires, notamment
la dissuasion.
Le ministère des Armées contribue
aussi à la cyberdéfense de la
nation, même si vous me permettez
de rester discrète à ce sujet.
Le service de renseignements
participe à ces manoeuvres.
Le ministère est en charge
de la réponse numérique.
Nous souhaitons que la France
reste dans le match des grandes
nations.
Pour développer notre capacité
de détection sur nos systèmes
et nos moyens de riposte,
nous devons utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle et le quantique.
Nous proposons de mettre en place
une filière d'excellence
autour de l'école polytechnique.
Nous souhaitons doubler la réserve
cyber qui est un pont
entre les entreprises et l'Etat.
C'est un effort auquel toute la
nation doit se préparer.
Le ministère des Armées prendra sa
part.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Paul-André Colombani pour le
groupe LIOT.
- Paul-André Colombani:
Ces mots sont ceux prononcés
récemment par le procureur de
Paris à la tête de la juridiction
nationale chargée de la lutte
contre la criminalité organisée.
Elle décrit l'essor vertigineux
du crime organisé en Europe.
La situation est pour le moins
inquiétante et les groupes mafieux
sont sans limites en termes de
financement et de recours à la
violence.
Des pays frontaliers comme les
Pays-Bas ou la Belgique constatent
avec impuissance l'emprise
grandissante de la mafia
qui menace leur fonctionnement
démocratique.
La Commission européenne s'est
emparée du sujet et annonce
vouloir légiférer en matière de
lutte contre le crime organisé.
La France n'est évidemment pas
épargnée par les phénomènes
mafieux.
Face à ce constat, vous l'avez dit
avec lucidité dans une interview
accordée au Parisien la semaine
dernière, il n'est plus possible
de fermer les yeux.
Je vous avais interpellé à ce
sujet sur la mise en place de
trois mesures réclamées par les
collectifs anti-mafia: la
nécessité d'une évolution du
repenti, la confiscation des
avoirs criminels et une évolution
législative inspirée des normes
ayant déjà fait leurs preuves en
Italie et dans le cadre du
dispositif qui protège le marché
public du tunnel Lyon-Turin.
Etes-vous prêt à placer ces
mesures au coeur de votre lutte
contre la mafia?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Eric
Dupond-Moretti, garde des Sceaux,
ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Monsieur le député Colombani,
votre question est intéressante.
Durant trop longtemps, nous avons
négligé ces phénomènes criminels.
Vous avez rappelé ce que des
organisations criminelles ont été
capables de faire en Belgique et
aux Pays-Bas.
La réponse est triple.
D'abord, une réponse européenne,
n'en déplaise aux eurosceptiques.
Qu'il me soit permis de dire que
récemment, les enquêtes communes
ont permis de démanteler les deux
plus gros trafics de drogue de
l'histoire.
Deuxième volet: il faut taper au
portefeuille.
La confiscation des avoirs
criminels.
Nous y travaillons.
Nous avons multiplié les antennes.
Nous sommes récemment allés avec
Gabriel Attal faire une vente qui
nous a rapporté beaucoup d'argent.
Nous avons la possibilité,
aujourd'hui, de confisquer des
immeubles et de les distribuer à
des associations caritatives.
Je veux remercier chaleureusement
un député avec qui nous
travaillons en permanence.
Troisièmement, le statut du
repenti.
Je suis allé récemment en Italie
pour m'inspirer de ce qu'ils font.
Ils connaissent depuis longtemps
les phénomènes mafieux.
Je veux remercier à cet instant
précis le président
de la Commission des lois
avec qui nous avons commencé
à travailler.
Un texte sera prêt à la fin de
l'année sur cette question des
repentis.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Alexandre
Holroyd pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Alexandre Holroyd: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de la
Transition écologique, un parc
immobilier zéro émission d'ici
2050, c'est l'ambition fixée par
le Parlement européen à
Strasbourg.
En cette journée de l'Europe qui
nous est si chère, c'est sur cet
objectif triplement essentiel que
je veux insister.
Essentiel parce que vital pour
notre planète.
Le bâti.
C'est essentiel pour le
portefeuille des Françaises et des
Français.
C'est important aussi pour notre
souveraineté nationale et
européenne, pour réduire
nos dépendances énergétiques.
Cette majorité, depuis plus de six
ans, s'est engagée pour réaliser
la décarbonation de notre parc
immobilier.
Ce matin, j'étais à vos côtés avec
notre collègue Thomas Cazenave
pour le lancement d'un vaste
chantier national.
C'est le chantier de la rénovation
thermique des écoles.
De quoi parlons-nous?
De 12 millions d'écoliers, de
collégiens et de lycéens,
d'écoles, de collèges et lycées,
de la France des six coins de
l'Hexagone.
Ce grand projet écologique doit
fédérer toutes les forces vives de
notre pays autour de cette
ambition alliant transition
écologique, vertus pédagogiques et
bon sens financier.
Monsieur le ministre, pouvez-vous
nous détailler comment, avec les
collectivités territoriales, vous
entendez garantir à nos
petits-enfants que leur école
répondra à l'objectif européen?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député
Alexandre Holroyd, vous avez
évoqué cette réunion de travail de
ce matin qui a permis à l'ensemble
des forces vives de se retrouver
autour de ce grand chantier promis
par le président de la République
et confié à la Première ministre
comme étant une des briques
essentielles de la planification
écologique.
130 millions de mètres carrés,
voilà la somme du bâti scolaire
dans notre pays.
Cela donne une idée des enjeux et
du triple enjeu qu'il y a
derrière.
C'est un enjeu climatique, un
enjeu budgétaire et un enjeu de
transmission.
Quand on apprend dans des
bâtiments qui sont trop chauds ou
trop froids, la qualité de la
transmission écologique ne se
passe pas dans les mêmes
conditions.
Il faut faire en sorte qu'il y ait
un cadre qui permette de le faire.
Cinq outils sont à disposition des
collectivités territoriales.
Il y a le fonds chaleur.
Il y a le fonds vert.
J'ai aussi le plaisir de vous
indiquer que sur les 1300 premiers
lauréats, 200 sont des bâtiments
scolaires qui vont bénéficier de
restaurations.
Il y a deux nouvelles.
Il y a le tiers financement.
La PPL de Thomas Cazenave a été
votée aujourd'hui même.
Ce que la Caisse des Dépôts lance,
c'est 10.000 écoles que nous
allons pouvoir rénover.
Ca va se décliner avec toutes
les associations d'élus.
Nous allons faire en sorte de
revenir vers tous les maires de
France avec une communication
ciblée, pour leur préciser les
moyens de relever ce chantier du
siècle pour le climat, le budget
et nos enfants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Marianne
Maximi pour La France Insoumise.
- Marianne Maximi: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, hier, nous avons
commémoré la victoire des Alliés
sur la barbarie nazie.
Samedi, des nostalgiques des
jeunesses hitlériennes défilaient
tranquillement à Paris avec des
proches de Marine Le Pen.
Depuis, silence sur les bancs des
ministres.
Vous qui êtes si prompts à
condamner et à interdire, votre
silence vaut-il approbation?
Des dizaines d'événements contre
la réforme des retraites sont
régulièrement interdits.
Cette manifestation était
autorisée par la préfecture, qui a
considéré qu'il n'y avait pas
de troubles à l'ordre public.
Comment le croire dans un contexte
où les agressions de l'extrême
droite se multiplient?
Des jeunes ont agressé des gens il
y a quelques jours car ils
n'étaient pas blancs.
Comment le croire quand la
préfecture, dans un arrêté du 5
mai, a autorisé l'emploi de drones
pour surveiller cette
manifestation pour prévenir les
risques d'atteinte à l'ordre
public?
La préfecture est de mauvaise foi
quand elle se cache derrière
le risque d'annulation
d'une interdiction
par le tribunal administratif.
De nombreuses interdictions de
manifestations contre la réforme
des retraites ont déjà été cassées
par la justice sans que cela vous
empêche de continuer d'en prendre.
Pourquoi ce deux poids deux
mesures?
Doit-on comprendre que
les casseroles sont plus dangereuses
pour l'ordre public
que les fascistes violents?
C'est malheureusement le message
que vous envoyez quand vous
permettez que le président fasse
vider les Champs-Elysées pour
défiler à l'abri des casseroles et
que l'on autorise le bruit des
bottes à retentir dans nos rues
grâce à la complicité du silence
des pantoufles du gouvernement.
Monsieur le ministre, cessez de
stigmatiser le peuple qui lutte.
Voyez-vous la violence
de l'extrême droite?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame Sonia
Backès, secrétaire d'Etat à la
citoyenneté.
- Sonia Backès: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, madame la
députée Marianne Maximi, la
Première ministre l'a dit: les
images que nous avons vues samedi
sont insupportables.
Oui, la boussole du ministère de
l'Intérieur est le respect de
l'Etat de droit et des décisions
de justice.
Le respect de l'Etat de droit est
de décider sur la base de la loi
et des décisions de justice si une
manifestation peut se tenir
ou pas.
Le respect de l'Etat de droit,
c'est une main qui n'a pas tremblé
pour la dissolution de 12
groupuscules d'extrême droite
depuis 2017.
C'est la dissolution des groupes
qui ont organisé des
manifestations racistes et
antisémites contre les homosexuels
et les transsexuels.
C'est l'interdiction par les
préfets de plusieurs
manifestations de droite
ces derniers mois à Montpellier, à
Paris et à Lyon.
Le respect de l'Etat de droit,
c'est l'enquête qui est en cours
sur l'agression dont a été victime
votre collègue, collaborateur
parlementaire.
Le respect de l'Etat de droit,
c'est la décision d'il y a
quelques instants
par Gérald Darmanin d'interdire
toutes les manifestations
d'ultradroite.
- Laurent Croizier: Electriciens,
menuisiers, agents de sécurité,
maçons, boulangers, conducteurs
d'engins, cuisiniers, comptables,
métiers de la petite enfance ou de
l'aide à la personne...
Au masculin comme au féminin, ces
métiers ont en commun de
travailler au quotidien auprès des
Français, et pour beaucoup d'entre
eux, de s'apprendre en lycée
professionnel.
Les députés démocrates considèrent
que la réforme du lycée
professionnel présentée jeudi
dernier par le président de la
République est un enjeu majeur
pour l'avenir de notre jeunesse et
un défi de ce quinquennat.
Le lycée professionnel accueille
un lycéen sur trois.
Il accueille majoritairement des
élèves qui cumulent les
vulnérabilités scolaires ou
sociales.
Il est malheureusement encore
aujourd'hui rarement un choix
alors qu'il forme des femmes et
des hommes qui seront les faiseurs
de nos grandes transitions, les
bâtisseurs des futures grandes
innovations et les acteurs de
l'accompagnement humain et social
qui nous est cher.
Pour toutes ces raisons, le groupe
démocrate est très exigeant sur
l'ambition de la réforme.
Le lycée professionnel se doit
d'être une voie de réussite
professionnelle, une voie de
réussite personnelle, une filière
d'excellence.
La réforme doit porter en elle la
promesse républicaine de
l'ascenseur social.
Aujourd'hui, seul un lycéen sur
deux parvient à l'emploi une année
après l'obtention de son diplôme.
Madame la ministre chargée de
l'Enseignement et de la Formation
professionnels, nous devons à ces
jeunes un parcours vers la
réussite, nous leur devons
l'égalité des chances.
L'objectif est de parvenir à 100%
d'insertion professionnelle.
Comment espérez-vous favoriser
l'insertion professionnelle?
Comment entendez-vous agir contre
le décrochage scolaire?
Comment comptez-vous réaffirmer le
lycée professionnel dans sa
mission d'ascenseur social?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député, je sais votre
engagement sur ce sujet.
Vous pouvez compter sur notre
engagement principal sur la
question de la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire.
C'est un enjeu majeur de cette
réforme.
Je tiens à le redire, il y a 10
fois plus de chances de décrocher
pour un élève venant du lycée
professionnel.
Deux tiers des décrochages
viennent de la voie
professionnelle.
C'est un enjeu majeur pour le
lycée professionnel, non pas du
fait des enseignants et des
équipes pédagogiques, mais de la
fragilité du système.
Plus faible niveau scolaire,
orientation subie, difficultés
diverses, jeunesse des élèves...
Toutes ces fragilités font que si
nous n'agissons pas, ces élèves ne
vont pas jusqu'au bout du
parcours.
Pendant le quinquennat précédent,
nous avons travaillé sur l'école
primaire.
Aujourd'hui, Pap Ndiaye accompagne
une réforme du collège.
Nous devons faire du lycée
professionnel un acteur engagé
pour lutter contre ce décrochage.
Cela passera par des moyens
inédits.
Plus d'un milliard d'euros par an
supplémentaires pour le lycée
professionnel, pour faire plus de
petits groupes pour accompagner
mieux les fragilités scolaires,
pour financer plus d'options, pour
accompagner des stages et
l'insertion professionnelle,
notamment le mentorat, avec un
ensemble de partenaires qui vont
nous accompagner, et organiser la
lutte contre le décrochage avec
les partenaires, tout ce réseau de
partenaires qui, très tôt, peut
venir nous aider à lutter contre
le décrochage.
C'est aussi travailler sur la
qualité des stages.
En parallèle de tout cela, c'est
travailler sur la découverte des
métiers, sur l'orientation
choisie, sur l'attractivité des
métiers.
France 2030 nous permettra
d'investir pour mettre en
visibilité des filières.
Enfin, le pacte du lycée
professionnel est orienté sur cet
objectif.
Nous n'allons lâcher aucun jeune,
ni avant le baccalauréat
professionnel et ni après le
diplôme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Valérie Bazin-Malgras.
- Valérie Bazin-Malgras: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le garde des Sceaux.
Je fais suite aux annonces du
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation de la justice que
vous avez présenté en Conseil des
ministres la semaine dernière.
L'embauche de 10.000 personnels
dont 1500 magistrats et 1600
greffiers est une bonne nouvelle
sur le papier qui tend à rassurer
et à donner enfin les moyens à
notre justice.
C'est un bon début, mais encore
bien insuffisant quand on sait que
pour un magistrat, il faudrait
au bas mot deux ou trois greffiers.
Je m'en suis rendu compte lors
d'une visite au tribunal
judiciaire de Troyes la semaine
dernière.
Plusieurs juridictions croulent
sous les stocks d'affaires à
gérer, faute de personnel
.insuffisant Les Français
attendent de vous des actes pour
désengorger les tribunaux.
Vous le savez, je défends mon
tribunal et je plaide pour son bon
fonctionnement.
Vous le savez aussi, l'ouverture
prochaine de la maison d'arrêt de
Troyes, qui est essentielle pour
notre territoire, va augmenter
l'activité du tribunal de Troyes.
Je vous ai déjà sollicité
plusieurs fois afin de pourvoir
les postes vacants, voire
augmenter les effectifs des
magistrats et des greffiers.
Afin de permettre à nos magistrats
du siège de gagner du temps et de
l'efficacité, il y a une mesure
que vous pourriez mettre en oeuvre
immédiatement, c'est de prendre un
décret pour autoriser la signature
électronique au civil, comme il
existe au pénal.
Cela simplifierait et soulagerait
les magistrats dans leur mission
de contentieux de soins
psychiatriques ou pour leurs
mesures d'isolement ou de
contention.
Quand prendrez-vous ce décret?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Madame la députée, d'abord, je
vous remercie de me poser cette
question.
Je voudrais dire ou redire, car
vous avez déjà dit les choses,
qu'il y avait d'abord une loi de
programmation.
Merci de souligner qu'elle va dans
le bon sens.
1500 magistrats, 1500 greffiers,
mais également des attachés de
justice en nombre pour aider nos
juridictions.
Ensuite, les moyens
réglementaires: je veux mettre en
place l'amiable en matière civile.
Troisième volet, le numérique.
Vous proposez le décret qui
pourrait être signé tout de suite
sur la signature électronique.
Je voudrais vous dire que vous
allez un tout petit peu vite,
parce qu'il faut d'abord que l'on
ait un outil pour conserver de
manière électronique les décisions
rendues.
On est en train de le mettre en
place.
Il sera en place dès cet automne.
Si votre juridiction qui vous est
si chère, et qui est aussi chère à
monsieur Baroin, le tribunal
judiciaire de Troyes souhaite
expérimenter cet outil, c'est
d'accord, qu'il me le fasse
savoir.
Je pense qu'ils ont en vous une
interlocutrice de qualité.
Qu'on me le fasse remonter.
Cette juridiction pourra
expérimenter cette signature
électronique.
Vous avez raison, il faut
absolument la mettre en place dès
cet automne.
Pas tout de suite, pardon de vous
décevoir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
2 secondes.
- Valérie Bazin-Malgras: J'ai bien
compris.
Mon tribunal sera candidat.
J'en suis certaine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Claude Raux.
- Jean-Claude Raux: Merci.
Madame la ministre, je me
garderais bien de critiquer
l'incritiquable réforme du lycée
professionnel annoncée à Saintes.
Je me contenterai de dire que nous
avons de la chance d'avoir un
président qui promeut l'exigence
pour les plus défavorisés sur le
plan scolaire, un président qui a
changé de méthode après l'absence
totale d'écoute et le mépris, la
concertation.
Sans des syndicats un peu trop
oubliés et des personnels
remplacés par une start-up,
rendez-vous compte de la chance
que nous avons: 1 milliard d'euros
pour la voie professionnelle, que
l'on pourrait presque appeler la
voie royale.
Et il va payer les élèves!
Ce sera toujours bon à prendre
pour faire adhérer les familles
les plus pauvres à la vision
présidentielle.
En plus, les élèves auront des
mentors, peut-être des retraités
bénévoles?
Non, ils seront au boulot et
beaucoup moins disponibles.
J'ai failli oublier le super pacte
proposé aux enseignants, du moins
celles et ceux qui resteront sur
place, parce qu'un certain nombre
de profs iront voir ailleurs.
Les élèves auront du temps en
plus, en terminale, enfin en
moins, parce qu'on avance
l'examen, mais de l'argent en
plus, s'ils arrêtent leur
solidarité pour finir sur des
stages pendant que les autres
profiteront du dernier trimestre.
Je vais citer le président
Emmanuel Macron: "Nous ne sommes
pas au rendez-vous de la promesse
que nous devons à ces élèves."
Peut-être que tout cela n'est
qu'une opération de com' bien
huilée pour se refaire une image
après le fiasco des retraites, un
cadeau de plus fait aux
entreprises, un miroir aux
alouettes pour les élèves et leurs
familles.
Je sais que vous allez nous
rassurer avec vos éléments de
langage, mais je vous le demande
quand même: dites-moi que cette
grande cause nationale n'est pas
en fin de compte une
instrumentalisation de
l'enseignement professionnel que
nous récusons de toutes nos
forces.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Carole
Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député, n'est-ce pas
vos propres éléments de langage,
il y a quelques semaines, lorsque
vous dénonciez le fait qu'il n'y
ait aucune annonce budgétaire qui
accompagnait l'évolution de la
carte des formations?
C'est tout l'inverse.
C'est plus d'un milliard d'euros
qui vont être investis dans le
lycée professionnel pour
accompagner cette préparation et
cette acquisition des compétences
qui permettront à ces élèves et à
ce pays de relever les grands
défis de la nation.
Nous accompagnerons cette carte
des formations par ce plan France
2030 avec plus de 2,5 milliards
d'euros consacrés aux formations
des enseignants, aux plateaux
techniques et à une meilleure
visibilité des filières.
Si les éléments de langage sont
bloqués sur ce sujet, pour notre
part, nous avançons.
Dans votre communiqué, vous
annoncez une pseudo-concertation.
Gare aux pseudo-vérités.
Nous n'avons eu de cesse
d'organiser ces concertations
par une large consultation de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
dès la rentrée 2022, constituées de
professeurs, d'élèves, de parents
d'élèves, d'académies, de
représentants des régions et
d'associations.
Plus de 160 personnes ont
participé à ces groupes de
travail.
Ce sont également des débats à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
qui ont eu lieu.
C'est évidemment des rendez-vous
réguliers avec les partenaires
sociaux.
Vous le voyez, cette réforme allie
méthode et ambitions.
Nous devons emmener le lycée
professionnel jusqu'au bout.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Henri
Alfandari.
- Henri Alfandari: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de la
Transition écologique, grâce à
l'action du gouvernement et au
travail effectué par la majorité
présidentielle, nous avons initié
ensemble des politiques
ambitieuses en matière de
transition énergétique et
écologique.
L'Etat s'engage financièrement
auprès des Français et des
collectivités pour être à la
hauteur de ses ambitions.
Néanmoins, comme plusieurs de mes
collègues, j'ai pu constater les
difficultés d'application sur le
terrain des décisions prises au
niveau national, notamment dues
aux instructions des différents
services déconcentrés de l'Etat.
Monsieur le ministre, vous avez
défendu la création d'un fonds
vert pour accompagner nos
collectivités dans leurs
investissements, notamment pour
les bâtiments publics.
Ces investissements sont
essentiels.
Nous devons limiter les émissions
et montrer l'exemple, mais aussi
limiter les factures énergétiques
pour garantir les services publics
que les collectivités rendent à
nos citoyens.
Je vais citer l'exemple d'une
commune qui a un projet de
chaufferie biomasse.
Ce projet était éligible au fonds
vert.
Or, pour être éligible, il faut
réunir au moins trois critères.
Comme l'isolation du bâtiment
avait été bien faite, le projet
n'en réunit que deux.
Il a donc été recalé, alors
qu'il ferait faire des économies.
Comment pouvez-vous intervenir
pour que cela ne soit pas abîmé
par des lourdeurs administratives?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député, ce fonds vert est victime
de son succès.
10.476, c'est le chiffre,
hier matin, du nombre de dossiers
déposés pour bénéficier
de ces crédits.
Cela représente une somme de
3,7 milliards d'euros de demandes
qui généreraient 16 milliards
d'euros de travaux.
On est au début du processus.
Le dépôt des dossiers a commencé
le 27 janvier.
Nous n'avons que 1527 lauréats.
Il n'y a que 200 millions d'euros
qui ont été attribués.
Le reste est en train de
s'examiner.
Comme n'importe quel dispositif
nouveau, il faut trouver le temps
et la bonne mécanique pour que ça
fonctionne.
Dans un premier temps, le fonds
vert, c'est autant à lui seul que
les deux anciens dispositifs
réunis.
Il y a des pré-arbitrages, et à la
fin, chaque département connaît la
somme qui lui est attribuée.
Je ne doute pas qu'on fera
véritablement en sorte de
consommer l'enveloppe disponible,
mais aussi de réfléchir sur les
projets efficaces.
Il y en a dans tous les
territoires.
L'Indre-et-Loire, c'est 91.
La Martinique, 63.
Le 24 mai, nous aurons la première
réunion de retour d'expérience
pour regarder ce que nous pouvons
encore simplifier.
Depuis le début, en refusant
l'appel à projets et en confiant
les crédits à la main des préfets
pour que ce soit souple et
déconcentré, on a voulu éviter ces
lourdeurs.
On va dans le détail regarder
comment respecter à la fois la
philosophie et les objectifs, mais
d'ores et déjà, cet outil de
territorialisation de
la planification écologique montre
bien que quand on accompagne
les élus locaux pour le climat, pour
la biodiversité, les résultats
sont au rendez-vous, et l'annonce
faite par la Première ministre de
ce dispositif le 11 avril dernier
va nous permettre de regarder
comment l'édition 2024 va nous
permettre d'avoir les avantages
sans les quelques inconvénients.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Lionel
Tivoli.
- Lionel Tivoli: Ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche, Sylvie Retailleau.
Suite à la crise de la Covid-19,
et maintenant l'hyperinflation qui
grève le pouvoir d'achat des
Français, les conditions de vie de
nos étudiants se sont largement
dégradées.
Chaque semaine, ce sont des files
d'étudiants qui se pressent pour
obtenir de l'aide alimentaire.
Vous prévoyez une nouvelle
augmentation de 5% de la
contribution vie étudiante et de
campus atteignant désormais la
barre des 100 euros.
Cette contribution est devenue un
impôt étudiant qui pénalise les
étudiants, notamment ceux des
classes moyennes.
Pire encore, cette CVEC est
devenue un dispositif financier au
service de la propagande woke.
Ce sont des projets délirants qui
sont financés au travers la CVEC,
pour servir l'extrême gauche.
L'objectif de la CVEC est
d'améliorer les conditions de vie
des étudiants.
Est-ce que le financement d'un
podcast sur les questions de genre
à l'université de Lyon ou
l'introduction à l'université de
Bordeaux du drag sont utiles?
En quoi est-ce que cela améliore
le cadre de vie de nos étudiants?
Il y a aussi des séances de
baby-foot non genré à l'université
d'Aix-Marseille.
Avez-vous l'honnêteté et le
courage de surseoir à cette
augmentation de la CVEC pour ne
pas aggraver les mauvaises
conditions de vie de nos étudiants
et de ne plus vous en servir pour
des délires wokes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Sylvie Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci.
Monsieur le député, d'abord,
permettez-moi de vous rappeler que
la CVEC, c'est effectivement la
contribution vie étudiante et vie
de campus.
La création de la CVEC a été
accompagnée de la suppression de
plusieurs cotisations qui étaient
à l'époque de la Sécurité sociale,
le fonds de solidarité
développement d'initiatives
étudiantes ou des cotisations sur
la santé étudiante.
Pour rappel, en comparaison, en
2018, un étudiant hors frais de
scolarité payait 238 euros.
En 2023, il payera 100 euros pour
la CVEC, c'est-à-dire une économie
pour chaque étudiant de 138 euros.
Je voudrais rappeler que le
législateur l'a indexée sur
l'inflation, évitant le gel.
Ca a aussi porté à 100 euros pour
2023 la CVEC.
Cette CVEC permet d'améliorer la
vie étudiante et de campus et
d'améliorer sur plusieurs axes.
Je voudrais rappeler le rôle
qu'elle a eu pendant la crise
sanitaire, pour aider les
étudiants isolés, pour aider le
passage au numérique, pour aider
les épiceries solidaires.
Au global, elle joue un rôle sur
cinq axes: sur un axe accueil
étudiant, sur un axe
d'accompagnement social, mais
aussi sur des axes
d'accompagnement sanitaire,
culturel et sportif.
Un autre exemple, l'université de
Caen a permis d'équiper avec
des équipements sportifs son campus
pour l'accès à tous les étudiants.
Cette CVEC joue un rôle très
important.
L'année dernière, 1,7 million
d'étudiants ont payé la CVEC,
ce qui a permis de récolter
150 millions d'euros.
Je voudrais préciser que
dans ces 150 millions d'euros,
127 ont été reversés aux Crous.
- Lionel Tivoli: Si je comprends
bien, vous rétablissez la double
peine, non pas pour les
délinquants, mais pour les
étudiants.
Vous braquez les étudiants non
boursiers et vous les prenez en
otages de vos délires wokes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-François Lovisolo.
- Jean-François Lovisolo: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, la ville
de Cavaillon, dans le Vaucluse,
a connu un événement dramatique
la semaine dernière sur fond de
trafic de stupéfiants.
Vous y étiez venu en août 2021
pour créer un groupe de sécurité.
Vos engagements ont permis un net
recul de la délinquance en 2022.
L'insécurité n'est pas une
fatalité.
Là où il y a une volonté, il y a
un chemin.
117 millions d'euros ont été
investis pour la rénovation
urbaine.
La politique de la ville est
ambitieuse et réussie.
Pour autant, le Vaucluse est un
territoire fragile.
Il y a eu un règlement de comptes
qui a fait deux morts dans la nuit
du 1er au 2 mai.
Dès le 2 mai au matin, je vous ai
contacté pour demander une
audience.
Cette rencontre a eu lieu vendredi
matin.
Votre réponse est sans précédent.
Il y aura 60 CRS affectés de
manière pérenne au département.
C'est une réponse forte.
La situation du Vaucluse l'exige.
Plus de 40 policiers vont être
ajoutés également sur Avignon et
Carpentras, entre autres.
Ce n'est pas fini.
Demain, nous allons travailler
conjointement sur le périurbain et
le rural.
Cela va nous permettre de
compléter le maillage territorial,
notamment dans le Vaucluse.
C'est le moment de vous dire merci
au nom des Vauclusiens, à
l'exception des élus du
Rassemblement National, qui n'ont
pas su se réjouir de cette bonne
nouvelle, car les échecs et les
immobilismes les font prospérer,
là où nos réponses les font
reculer.
Je vous interroge sur le délai du
déploiement de ces forces
supplémentaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député, je voudrais
évidemment saluer votre action en
tant que député élu dans le
Vaucluse, ainsi que le maire de
Cavaillon mais aussi le maire de
Carpentras et la maire d'Avignon
pour le travail qu'ils font auprès
des forces de l'ordre.
Vous avez raison, le Vaucluse
connaît un regain de trafic de
drogue depuis quelques années,
mais nous faisons reculer ce
trafic.
19 kg de cannabis ont été saisis.
Il n'y a plus que 63 points de
deal.
C'est quand même 63 de trop, bien
sûr.
Après 9 à 10 mois de calme, dans
la belle ville de Cavaillon, le
trafic reprend, et avec le maire
de Cavaillon, que j'ai reçu, je
veux confirmer les annonces que
j'ai pu faire.
43 policiers de plus en septembre
prochain, et une unité de CRS dans
le Vaucluse tout au long de
l'année.
Il y aura 200 policiers de plus,
si je compte les 92 policiers
supplémentaires que nous avons mis
en place depuis deux ans dans le
département du Vaucluse.
Ce sont des moyens sans précédent.
Vous êtes le seul député non
Rassemblement National du
Vaucluse.
Sur cinq députés, il y a un député
qui n'est pas du Rassemblement
National.
Vous avez apporté des réponses à
des élus qui ne sont pas dans
votre circonscription.
Nous avons trouvé des réponses.
Je regrette qu'il ait fallu
attendre que vous soyez le seul
député à louer les efforts de la
police nationale, du recul du
trafic de drogue.
Manifestement, ils se
désintéressent de leur
département.
On essaie de résoudre les
problèmes, d'autres vivent avec.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Joël Aviragnet.
- Joël Aviragnet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Education nationale, la
République française s'est
construite et ancrée comme un
idéal d'émancipation grâce à
l'école.
Les fameux hussards noirs, de par
leur engagement au service du
pays, ont permis à des générations
entières d'accéder à l'éducation.
Une école forte est la garantie
pour une nation d'un avenir
serein.
La situation de l'école est
extrêmement inquiétante.
L'été dernier, on apprenait que
l'Etat n'arrivait pas à recruter
suffisamment de professeurs
qualifiés car le nombre de
candidats était en forte baisse.
Les parents d'élèves constatent,
impuissants, que les professeurs
absents ne sont pas remplacés.
Dans ma circonscription, dans un
collège près de la frontière
espagnole, un professeur n'a pas
été remplacé pendant près d'un an.
Un peu plus loin, même situation
avec un professeur de français,
alors que ses élèves devaient
passer le bac.
Selon le principal syndicat
d'enseignants du primaire, le
nombre de fermetures de classes
était mi-mars de 4944 pour 2685
ouvertures, soit un solde négatif
de 2959 classes.
Encore une fois, les territoires
ruraux vont payer le plus lourd
tribut.
Il est inacceptable de voir nos
services publics fermer les uns
après les autres.
La baisse de la démographie pour
expliquer la fermeture des classes
n'est pas une réponse adaptée.
Vous avez annoncé une
revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants dès la rentrée
prochaine.
C'est une annonce positive.
Nous devons renforcer
l'attractivité de ce métier.
Que comptez-vous faire pour
assurer le remplacement des
professeurs absents, comme l'a
promis le président de la
République?
Pourquoi ne pas se saisir de la
baisse démographique pour
améliorer les conditions
d'enseignement à l'école, plutôt
que de fermer des classes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député, le travail de
la carte scolaire s'exerce dans un
contexte de baisse démographique
que vous avez rappelé.
En moins de 10 ans, la France est
passée de 830.000 à 738.000
naissances par an.
C'est 500.000 élèves de moins qui
sont attendus d'ici à 2027.
Attachée au service public de
l'éducation pour tous les
territoires, la Première ministre
a annoncé un plan pour l'école
dans les territoires ruraux et un
changement de méthode.
Sur les fermetures de classes,
avec une approche nouvelle, une
approche en concertation avec les
élus, afin de trouver des réponses
adaptées aux territoires.
Le ministre a déployé 400 postes
supplémentaires pour éviter les
fermetures de classes dans
certains territoires ruraux.
Pour votre territoire, la
fermeture envisagée n'est pas
concernée.
Cette décision finale sera prise
en juin prochain.
S'il n'y a pas de fermetures de
classes pour l'école en question,
c'est 17,5 élèves par classe qui
seront présents à la rentrée 2023.
S'il y a une fermeture, ce sera 23
élèves par classe.
C'est conforme aux engagements
portés par le président de la
République et la Première ministre
ainsi que le ministre.
C'est une vigilance particulière
pour la ruralité qui est accordée.
Vous êtes en lien avec des
interlocuteurs de l'Education
nationale sur votre territoire.
Vous savez que de nouveaux
territoires éducatifs ruraux
seront ouverts à la rentrée
prochaine sur votre territoire.
Vous aurez la même énergie pour
les valoriser, j'en suis sûre.
Comptez sur la nôtre.
Le gouvernement prend en compte la
problématique des écoles en milieu
rural.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La séance des questions au
gouvernement est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.